hi all this is just a short channel
update recently i've been conducting a
lot of surveys of people and asked a lot
of people to comment on things about the
channel and i want to give you an update
on how that's going so as you might have
realized i've had the great opportunity
to bring on a lot of authors firsthand
on the channel to explain their papers
explain what they think and sort of the
behind the scenes stuff of the research
and this is this is amazing i would have
never thought that so many people would
want to you know come on and share
things with the audience but you know
here we are it was really cool for the
people i guess to come on because they
get to share their work it was really
cool for me because i got to interview
the people and then after that i would
make the paper review which would be
shorter more condensed because we'd
already cover so much in the interview
and i thought that would sort of be you
know a good piece of content however it
was not so good for you a lot of you and
i've read a lot of comments i've
conducted surveys you might have come
across them on youtube on twitter and so
on a lot of you missed the old style
paper reviews the longer paper reviews
and you pointed out some crucial things
first of all it is really difficult to
be critical of a paper when you make the
paper review after interviewing the
authors because that's what i would do i
would let the authors explain the paper
to me essentially so i know even more
when doing the review and then after
that i'd record the review however it'd
be a real dick move if i were to bring
up some sort of criticism in the paper
review that i didn't bring up in the
interview right because you know what am
i gonna do interview the authors and
then be like well but this part here
this is really crap and then the authors
have no chance of responding i mean it's
not a good way of doing things so i was
not able to be as critical as i would be
when i would just approach the paper for
myself not that i want to be critical
but it was just a different atmosphere
so i've decided going forward that i
would do
the paper review first in its full
length in its sort of classical way and
then
show that to the authors and then
interview the authors this allows us to
get into the criticism and into the meat
of the paper much more quickly and also
a little bit more of that behind the
scenes stuff it will make the interviews
a bit shorter as well and i think that
will just be an improvement for everyone
it does represent a bit more work for
myself but you know that's life yeah
it's essentially whatever i did before
plus the interviews plus the most
dreaded part which is like scheduling
and organizing all the people which is
really not something i'm good at but i'm
trying so if you're something that's
kind of like expecting an email from me
for like four weeks i'm sorry i'm really
sorry
yeah what's still not clear to me is
whether or not to release the
videos in one part or to release the
review and the interview separately
maybe back to back on two different days
or whether to release them apart from
each other like the review as soon as i
have it and then the interview later
people are kind of split between the two
methods and we'll just have to
experiment a bit so going forward there
will be classic paper reviews and if
there is an author coming on the author
will be able to react to the
pay-per-view not always it's not always
going to be possible it does require
more work on deadlines for me and i
don't always have time to prepare the
review before i interview but i'm trying
as best as i can so there are about two
or three videos in the backlog that
still have the old format and then after
that we're gonna switch to the new
format and it will be glorious i really
want to thank everyone who's contributed
to finding this uh to tell me what they
think you know all the commenters all
the people on discord all the people who
took part in surveys thank you very much
i want to do as best as i can i want to
make the best use of your time when i
make the best use of the author's time
and i hope this is just going to lead to
greater content please as we continue to
experiment with stuff let me know what
you think continue to tell me what is
best for you continue to tell me what
you didn't like and with that i'll see
you around ciao
[Music]
you